jamais ça plus jamais ça le déficit du
budget de la ville de fort de france
c'est le sujet brûlant au coeur de la
campagne pour les élections municipales
tous les candidats dans la ville
capitale en place et l'assainissement
des finances de la ville
en tête des priorités c'est la liste du
redressement de fort de france
c'est la liste de l'espérance instauré
pour fort de france
c'est la liste de la volonté politique
pour sortir fort de france de la
situation où l'a entraîné un système
dont on voit aujourd'hui les méfaits
puis à la ctm en charge des finances
publiques vous savez que nous avons
trouvé une situation déficitaire
aujourd'hui avec l'impulsion donnée par
le président marie jeanne nous avons une
situation qui est non seulement assainie
mais qui aujourd'hui ouvre des
perspectives
parce que nous avons pu faire à une
échelle heureusement moins grave que ce
que nous découvrons à fort de france
eh bien je crois que nous pouvons le
faire pour fort-de-france
celui qui met en avant son expérience de
conseiller exécutif en charge des
finances promet de ne pas augmenter les
impôts locaux pour redresser les
finances de fort de france il assure
pouvoir aller chercher des ressources
ailleurs la diminution de la population
est plus rapide à fort de france que
dans l'ensemble de la martinique et par
conséquent aujourd'hui il faut trouver
de la ressource ailleurs alors il faut
aller la chercher
notamment au niveau national parce que
nous par appartenant à la république
française et que nous avons la
responsabilité parce que c'est notre
droit d'aller rechercher les moyens que
la république doit pouvoir nous donner y
compris quand ils sont exceptionnels
nous devons aller les chercher ailleurs
de la république c'est à dire notamment
en europe avec sa liste qui représente
les forces martiniquaises de progrès il
dénonce le dépérissement de la ville
baisse de la population centre-ville en
difficulté insécurité ces mesures il les
annoncera durant sa campagne
miguel laventure à cinq semaines pour
convaincre